so I want to start today with something
that gives me great pleasure it's video
of our friend Congressman Jamie Raskin
who appeared on this program not long
ago and who I think is doing an
excellent job
basically making a fool out of
Republican Congressman Thomas Massey
because Massey sees conspiracies
everywhere now in particular in this
clip it's all about Ray Epps now if you
haven't heard about Ray Epps I'm going
to tell you about him in a moment but
it's important that you know before we
look at the clip there are some on the
right
who believe that an individual named Ray
Epps who appeared in Washington DC on
January 5th in some videos is either an
agent or an asset or an informant of the
FBI who essentially encouraged trumpists
to do what they did on January 6th and
that the entire thing was staged slash
encouraged by the FBI there is no
evidence for this whatsoever Republicans
some are obsessed with it and Jamie
Raskin in this clip rightly points out
to Massey why is everything a conspiracy
to you and take a look at the first few
seconds alone are extremely informative
Mr Epps was in front of the January 6
committee and we were told that a
transcript of his interview would be
released but it's never been released
and I wondered was he sworn none of the
transcripts have been released so you
don't need a conspiracy theory about
that we haven't released anything so the
on this is such a it's it's just the
beginning of this clip but it's so
important a lot of these right Wingers
love to say
hey but what about this this is
suspicious and oftentimes the this is
just the way things are done and so in
this case Massey says you haven't
released the transcript from when we
spoke to Ray Epps and Jamie Raskin says
we've done a thousand interviews we
haven't released any transcripts there's
nothing special about Ray Epps it's sort
of like when uh Republicans claim voter
fraud
and you say okay well what what is the
basis for that claim and they say well
the pictures of every scanned ballot
haven't been released to us that's never
done in any state even states where the
margin of Victory is massive that's not
that's not something that's a red flag
okay let's continue when he was
interviewed that'll give me no I was not
I was not we've done more than a
thousand interviews you guys are trying
to make this poor schmuck who showed up
to your protest into something a lot
bigger than he is okay he's just trying
to survive and he's on your side you
don't have many voters left you might
want to try to hang on to them without
demonizing and vilifying your own people
isn't that great that's the Donald Trump
way so everybody else down the road
unless you can get a pardon some people
are still hanging around waiting for
their pardon
but most people have opened their eyes
about what he's done to our country
when he's done to his family have you
guys ever read the book by Mary Trump
about the way that Donald Trump is
absolutely destroyed their family
wrecked her father's life
they do it to family they do it to
friends they do it to their own
Associates and employees and now you
guys are doing it to this poor Ray Epps
leave that guy alone whoever he is
so very nicely done by Jamie Raskin and
they love to see conspiracies everywhere
even when there are none there's a
really good factcheck.org article about
the entire Ray Epps thing the quick take
is Ray Epps was at the Capitol
but there is no evidence he was an FBI
plant
uh there is evidence that EPS once held
their leadership role in The Oath
Keepers some of whose members have been
charged in the attack Ray Epps is a 60
year old he owns a wedding venue in
Phoenix Arizona the FBI put a picture of
him on a list of people they were
seeking information about
and the conspiracy theories about Ray
Epps include he just doesn't really seem
like a random insurrectionist he seems
more like law enforcement the other
circumstantial claim that's made by some
trumpists is he was on a list of people
the FBI wanted to talk to and suddenly
he was off the list well maybe it's
because the FBI found him and talked to
him everything is a conspiracy with
these people and they should be
ridiculed the way that Jamie Raskin did
I saw a funny comment on Twitter that
Thomas Massey really has Milton from
Office Space Vibes you know the guy who
uh where is where is my stapler but
that's my that's my favorite stapler it
is very accurate there is that exact
vibe to Thomas Massey and Ray Epps
Raskin calls him a poor schmuck maybe I
wouldn't go that far uh but he's
certainly a right winger and he was
certainly in Washington DC on January
5th 6th and he certainly is not an FBI
plan one of our longtime sponsors is
monk pack offering low sugar plant-based
keto-friendly bars I love these they are
the perfect snack for anyone trying to
eat better or cutting back on sugar and
carbs without sacrificing taste monk
pack offers granola bars and nut and
Seed bars each with only one gram of
sugar or less two to three net carbs and
150 calories or less I'm a big fan of
the macadamia white chocolate nut and
Seed bar great combination of sweet
salty chewy and crunchy and there's
under one gram of sugar they come in
other awesome flavors like sea salt dark
chocolate coconut cocoa chip and caramel
sea salt monk pack is great if you're
doing Keto so I don't do keto but monk
pack is just great for anyone who wants
something delicious On The Go without
the sugar and my audience gets 20 off
your first order at monkpak.com when you
use the coupon code Pacman at checkout
the link is down below